here's what I'm gonna do I want to show
you another property of pastors triangle
and make that my segue into the binomial
term okay it's not going to be a proof
would just be a demonstration okay so
here we go you remember I told you that
what was the last property I showed you
remember it was the crazy was the prime
numbers first we noticed that none of
these guys in here were prime if the
only primes appear in this counting
numbers diagonal diagonals because
symmetrical okay and then we noticed in
those plant rows there were some weird
funky patterns okay guess what
I was just getting started okay now this
one has to be harder to do with the rows
I could show you all the rows at once
and here we've got the problem is a 3 3
5 7 11 those are ones that aren't here
right but for this one I'm need to get
it going to need to go all over the
triangle so I can only do it for one
number of time but hopefully it'll be
enough to show you okay now here's what
we're going to begin the smallest prime
number
smalls prime number two right eye as of
row it's not that interesting right like
you know how we sell all the core
factors of fire or factors of 7 or
factors of 11 okay but there are factors
of 2
I'm not in this row right help me find
him ok I already here okay oh thank you
yes ok cool ok next row where the
factors the middle to G okay how about
this one where the fact is you've got
this guide alternates doesn't it okay
now so far you're like is there
something here well it's symmetrical but
of course it's symmetrical does the
triangle symmetrical but let's just wait
and see what happens okay
are there more more numbers that are
even not here because there are factors
of seven right and nothing else the even
numbers here there are actually all of
them except for the ones right
um how about here are the factors all
except the nines right am I missing any
on the next one let's see well 10 is
tens one cool he's hanging out there on
his own
of course he's every second one yeah how
light in the middle well you skip to 45
you get these guys and the 10 yep
next 934 even numbers there are there
sure are from here now I wonder
I mean I've run out of space on the
board but I wonder where you see is
going um this shape it has a name this
shape it has a name it kind of looks
like this
now I could be standing here a long time
in fact I could be standing here for
infinite time and I could never finish
because this is this shape actors a
couple of days but the broad category of
shape is this is called fractal right it
is it is self-similar as you zoom in for
instance see this part here just look at
that see that it's like a version of
mini version of the whole thing all
right can you see can you see those four
triangles in this one here here and here
yeah you see it okay each and I can keep
going in if I if I kept drawing or if I
if I could keep drawing right you see
them in the numbers the further it goes
this triangle completes look you've got
these guys here which kind of stand for
these little triangles right but then
you've got these triangles and I'll get
more if I couldn't draw more okay now
generally it's called fractal this
particular front door because it's got
triangles in it was discovered by this
guy see if it's key so you've got you've
got Pascal's triangle and within it is
sierpinski's triangle okay now why did I
show you that I showed me that
personally to convince you if you
weren't convinced already there is some
crazy black magic stuff happening in
this triangle okay you know Reed pens
we're just scratching the surface